[Music]
one boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation we are very excited to be
talking about technology for human
flourishing and we have an epic guest
with us today to talk about this
Andrew Marie Dunn AKA ava rose what's up
thanks for having me this is so fun
thanks for coming on to the show greatly
appreciate it this can be a lot of fun
we got a lot to unpack about this is
kind of coming at a really important
time with the attention economy being
criticized and under the sort of there's
a lot of issues with it yeah
okay and let's let's unpack you know
we'll get to some of the ethical tech
and tech for human flourishing stuff I
want to start with this because you came
in here and you kind of dropped some
interesting life trajectory on to me
about you and so you you said that you
know you were playing around with gender
fluidity and a new name Ava Rose and you
just come back from Burning Man and
there's like tell unpack this for us
first let's get to know you and then
we'll also get to know what you're
building as well yeah thanks for asking
about it because I find I have a lot to
share having gone to Stern II and this
is such a funny forcing function for me
to actually make some decisions about
who I want to be yeah publicly so yeah I
I have been trying to connect with a
more true expression of myself over the
last couple of years through mindfulness
and other consciousness expanding
technologies and a series of interesting
events transpired to make me feel
comfortable asking the question where do
I feel like I am on this spectrum of
gender identity and gender expression
also sexual orientation and you know
this gender unicorn layer-cake thing
that it's just not really on the menu
when we're growing up but now with trans
movement women's empowerment movements
talk of civilizational imbalances
between
feminine they're just a lot more
awareness of you know these different
energies that we all have and so yeah
just in trying to figure out like where
am i what feels good and a at Burning
Man this new name came to me because I
kind of felt like my older identity was
dissolving and something new was
emerging in its place what I call that
and so Ava Rose came through pretty
instantly I was thinking about what
would be symbolic so andrew is inspired
by my Hebrew name Avraham hmm so Ava was
a derivative of that Rose is my
grandmother's name so I thought it'd be
cool to honor the female lineage in
addition to my surname which is
obviously male yeah and yeah it just
sounded really sweet and so I've been
playing with it and I'm really lucky to
be living in this time and in this place
where I feel really safe I acknowledge
that it's not the experience that most
people yeah but yeah it's really cool
how yeah this journey has taught me a
lot about you know social systems and
empathy for others and it's really a
great gift to be able to share that with
others and inspire them so what does it
feel like kind of surfing through that
spectrum to find where you're at yeah
there's there's a whole bunch of things
you can play with you know like how I'm
dressed mannerisms voice things like
pronouns name I think for me it's been
really important to to meet other people
in the LGBTQ community and understand
their experiences and their stories and
then yeah it's a step into these
different expressions like
self-expression is always been a big
edge for me getting out my head into my
body yeah so in a way it's like the
universe is giving me a big slap in the
face with a bunch of reasons to start
doing that and that's been really
wonderful you know I I wasn't going to
dance classes I wasn't yeah I just
wasn't doing some of the same things in
my day to day existence that I am doing
now which are providing me with access
to more body wisdom and more
understanding what it's like to be
female in this world a little bit yeah
that's so I'm just so curious because
you know I just hosted we just hosted
women in Alliance on Friday and we had
this this really powerful female panel
that we had and we were talking about
exactly you were mentioning earlier with
this whole civilizational kind of
figuring out how the feminine rising and
how that's changing and transitioning
civilization and so you know at times I
definitely feel like I am just this you
know bundle of like loving and just more
more closer to the heart energy and but
I I'm curious like what does that does
that mean that I'm not a hundred percent
male because I think I guess you know
how does one figure that out that do you
do you how do you feel about that well
first kudos for acknowledging that and
it sounds like you feel kind of good
about that yeah that's how to do yeah
I'm still figuring it out like this
stuff is complicated I'm still trying to
figure out like you know in the
spiritual communities there's masculine
feminine energy is Shakti Shiva
Yin Yang but then we have more societal
constructs about what it means to be
male female or what things are
considered masculine or feminine in
general yeah I mean I didn't know about
like this gender binary that we have
well I was living in it I was swimming
in it but I didn't know that it was a
thing that we kind of impose on others
because of your sign they'll at birth it
just comes with all this baggage your
sign theme of birth all this baggage and
it hasn't really been an option on the
menu for young people to really explore
the in-between but nature is infinitely
complex and yeah I think that it's it's
a really cool thing that because of
social media because of community
building that can happen over the
Internet
we're now able to see more expressions
of what's possible so people can you
know they're now able to be what they
can now see and yeah I think that is
promoting more acceptance in some places
maybe not others but yeah I think it's I
think it's all good because
we'll get into later with this tech for
flourishing we have a pretty homogenous
group of people creating tech and yeah
it's it's gotten us to amazing places
and I like to ask what would more
balance look like yeah if we're creating
from a more hearts in our place could we
have products that really nourish the
soul and serve the whole yeah with real
regard for long-term consequences and
you know I don't have the answers to
those either but I feel like we're the
masculine-feminine is like such a major
civilizational divided and there's this
amazing story I think it's a bahai story
Bahai by yeah which is what again that
is it's the religion yeah in Asia and in
like Indian area I believe it started in
the Middle East middle of my ignorance
okay round me to three okay it's the
story is that the bird of humanity has
been flying with only its masculine wing
for the last two thousand years that's
an interesting way to put it yeah and
that wing has gotten so strong
aggressive and exhausted and because
we've only been flying with one wing
we've been going in circles we keep
forgetting stuff we keep yeah now the
feminine wing is starting to express
itself realize its strength which is
allowing the masculine wing to rest so
the bird of humanity can soar yeah yeah
inspires me yeah like holy that came
from bhai that's what my Google search
results showed the interesting yeah
definitely look into that that's pretty
cool yeah I like that I like the I like
talking about these analogies like the
but the feminine wings been doing like a
tremendous amount of work especially
with raising children and providing oh
yeah yes so there's like there's been an
interesting sort of but but I hear how
the masculine one's been beating was in
terms of jism yeah growing civilization
and in especially in the ways of
business and technology right which have
caused a lot of that oh look we're not
we haven't slowed down and thought about
tech for flourishing we're more so
concerned with money yeah
Sharyl shareholder capitalism which
which in in a sense you can't also the
imperialistic tendencies of
nation-states are also something to be
concerned about because if you don't
follow a capitalistic paradigm you can
get conquered which is also kind of you
know there's a nuance to this equation
it's complicated yeah it's just like you
know how you feel right now yeah and I'm
still so interested in just that notion
of you know when when a child is born
into the world if they're given these
options and they're given the ability to
explore um you know gender fluidity and
and just a spectrum of how to of how to
of how they feel that seems to be very
important but it can also seem to be at
times potentially like it could lead
them into something that they may not be
and then they might have to figure that
out later yeah I'm no parenting expert
but from the little bit of developmental
psych I I know it seems like it's
important that parents allow their
children to express themselves yep and
and not to be it's like so forceful
about which direction that goes in and
not to yeah you know reprimand them for
for trying to do so yeah that's right so
yeah ya know I think nature wants to
express itself neutral teacher want to
express that we should let it flow yeah
and interestingly enough in evolution
doesn't have a stopping function there's
no continuous growth function in
evolution and we have we're so ignorant
about all the nuanced evolution how are
we ever gonna be able to figure out
everything that goes into this equation
hopefully we'll figure it out everything
working on it working on it yeah okay so
yeah let's move into the conversation
about tech for human flourishing I just
want to end that portion by saying it's
really epic to be here with you at your
moment of transition from and remarried
unto every rose and you know you're on
your Saturn return right now it's like
you know a straw astrological sort of
understanding of planetary energy and
and celestial body energy and it's it's
it's an honor to be here with you as you
explore your fullest self and and I and
I do I I do wonder the whole seven years
you become a new person thing I wonder
how you know changing a name on that
would we're stuck with this one name for
ninety years or whatever so I wonder
know what would it be like to change a
name every seven years and yeah all this
different kind of stuff it's a huge
opportunity I coincidentally was doing
this inner critic exercise a couple of
weeks ago where I was listening out all
the things that my inner critic tells me
like you're not a good listener
you don't learn fast enough and then I
should have a thought well if I flip
that and said like in the affirmative
Ava's a great listener Ava learns
quickly and so on and so forth yeah and
that gave me like a great roadmap for
who I want to be so yeah it's really
funny to think about pivoting one's
identity to you start up terms yeah as
I'm in the pivot of a business - yep but
in a way it's yeah I think business and
personal especially in the leadership
position like they're mirrors for each
other and so yeah it's really cool to
see how I'm growing along with how the
business is evolving and the business is
just an expression of who I am and what
I value all my fears and biases and so
yeah you know then it's like I got on
this whole like transformative work I'm
trying to do it's better myself so I can
make a better product that actually
helps people and yeah a lot swirling
around these days yes I like how you
made it clear the way that you kind of
communicate with yourself a lot of
people can get stuck in a sort of I'm
not gonna know if I'm not gonna know if
I'm good enough but there's also another
way to look at things which is that hey
like where I'm at right now is it's
where I'm at with the resources that I
have and in that I I want to do better
and this is how I can do better and
there's this other mentality of like
keeping a sort of moment to moment bliss
Uruk status on mhm just life moving yeah
okay alright tech for flourishing yes ah
yeah let's do the name change I thought
you had maybe already done that yeah
alright for that yeah for the call so
yeah so we have we have we're gonna
transition from the featuring Andrew
Murray done I'm nervous yeah it's like
the first yeah it's like the first sort
of yeah the first step and seeing it you
know and yeah this is another thing I
was wondering how you how one would
handle this in terms of social accounts
just the fact that you've already poured
years into the social accounts and now
you're changing names which means you
have to you know change social accounts
and many of these settings yeah and
that's more years of growth how do you
tell your followers how do you tell your
parents right and then you know what if
you want it then we were talking about
changing it again everything here's
where it's like how do you head I'll let
you know I don't know but I'm not too
worried about it I I think maybe a few
years ago I might have been attached to
like how I'm controlling the messaging
yeah and yeah how I communicate to my my
people yeah and maybe what people would
think about it but I don't know like
just not as attached one life tweet
anywhere one life yeah yeah yeah it's in
service of my growth and the work I'm
doing him yeah you know inspiring and
influencing others so okay and let's
talk about that so now we're at you know
how long has she been around she has
been around about three years and now
we're going through our third pivot it
started as a minimal feature phone then
it was a mindful smartphone then it was
a humane smartphone interface and now
we're launching a space race to build
was enlighten the operating system
I love it okay yeah that's okay so let's
let's unpack because cm Poe when you
were going to University of Pennsylvania
and you're going to Warren which is the
business school yep doing economics
I ain't learned anything about economics
but that was my degree business and is
it more business then
yeah well learning about mostly correct
yeah yeah Business School yeah and it's
so interesting you have degrees in econ
I didn't learn anything about econ
that's this classic sort of collegiate
process well it's a gift now because I
don't understand the conventional wisdom
I just focus on like my intuition in the
sense yeah yeah how this was a whole
separate conversation about the
collegiate degrees and stuff so uh when
did when did it strike you that you
wanted to do tech for flourishing did it
strike you in university or did it
strike you when he came out here and
what was it will pull do out here so a
year after I graduated I was living in
India working with a friend on the
business and I I think in India for any
spiritual growth or anything I just had
the opportunity to see the world and I
had my first night without Wi-Fi the
might sound trivial but it was the first
night in a decade because I I'm a
millennial I got my phone at 12 and
computer in my room and stuff and I I
really felt like it was a decade of
hypnosis by technology and I'm you
didn't go a day without it yeah probably
not and that that you remember yeah yeah
that's crazy and I was really hooked on
social media on messaging how many of us
are lying yeah yeah and then I was
traveling by myself and I found myself
in a town I'd never heard of that day no
Wi-Fi and just a notebook and a book I
picked up and it was just like a decade
of act jumping through hoops and
go-go-go and socialization like just
came to a stop yeah and it was just like
whoa like what am I Who am I would have
I been doing
mm-hm and like why I had why have I been
doing it and I just I felt so high on
life for a week
I was so
more clear and creative and present and
just like inspired motivated to I don't
know to to to be more to rise to the
fullest expression of what I could be
and that was about five years ago and so
I kind of traced that moment back to my
personal journey because I started just
questioning more things and being more
intentional and trying to live my truth
and I was really trying to figure out
better habits to build healthy
relationships with my devices and apps I
found it really hard because there were
just a few productivity apps at the time
no one was really talking about this so
I was just testing a bunch of things and
manual processes trying to set my
systems for success and nothing was
really working too well I was making
incremental changes but it became a very
iterative process long term process
because new technologies come in like
dating apps weren't that popular until
at that time and then snapchat wasn't
popular and then you know so on so I I
came back to the States
I was working for some other tech
companies and it was very clear that
when I was away from my phone in the
shower on the hayek you know festival I
was so much more alive so I just kept
coming back to man how could we balance
the power of these things with how that
can enrich our lives and I wound up
leaving that company and started working
on the wearable it was a ring that we
let you record voice notes when you were
away from your devices so you could get
those nuggets of wisdom down ideas
recommendations whatever and love that
idea
yeah like this is such a huge fan of
that idea
Thanks because this is one of the only
reasons why I'm attached to my device
because I love taking notes and yeah
yeah of the ideas because I want to keep
them I don't want them to flow away
right
and you come back to them and then they
manifest yeah yeah exactly so it could
be an amazing tool that's great and
insult photo photo was also nice because
I'm in a document visually as well but
yeah yeah throw a little tiny camera
yeah yeah it was fun to play the form
factor and see what we could squeeze in
anyways
I by chance wound up at a hardware
meetup one
and I chicken out of karaoke the
previous night so this night I was like
okay I'm gonna go up there and pitch
this because you know III need to and so
I did and then this other guy was
pitching a mindful phone and our stories
sounded kind of similar so it was kind
of this love it for a site type thing
because I hadn't met anyone else was
thinking critically about this humane
type type stuff and so he started giving
me some side projects and eventually I
joined their team full-time I was just
more inspired of what they were doing
they had some funding so I joined them
we were we were doing a Kickstarter
campaign to validate if this Harbor path
for the mindful smartphone made sense
and we got a lot of buzz but the
switching costs were just super high for
people to leave their iPhone for this
brand new thing that no one's tried to
endorse yeah and the the request was
like hey I would definitely try and pay
for a software version of this can you
do that it turns out on Android we can
do pretty much anything yeah so it was a
clear pivot and the process the existing
co-founders they've been working on this
for a couple years and they scaled back
their involvement and I came into the
leadership role yep and so the last year
has been spent figuring out yeah like
what does a better smartphone interface
look like that supports our mental
health and well-being respects our time
and attention their nervous system and
so we basically taken a behavior design
approach to figure out how we would
design the interface to reduce overuse
reduce unconscious use and help you feel
better about your device and so we
launched that about six months ago and
it's been crazy because you know it's
kind of like a Silicon Valley episode
it's like you know crazy press like run
out of money like someone leaves the
company like crazy opportunity happens
it's just it's been all over the place
and that is the roller coaster yeah of
entrepreneurship I love it yeah like
yeah described it so perfectly all those
different things going on in short
periods of time yeah it's not venture
and that is that's that's interesting
that you ended up taking the leadership
as it pivoted towards software right and
I think the software pivot was a
brilliant idea it's really difficult to
give people some want to switch hardware
yeah okay so as you pivot to software
then I love the things that you listed
especially the
the decreasing unconscious use yep we
don't even we don't even have realized
when we open up our phone that were
pushed notifications that have been
sitting there waiting for us to open up
the phone so they can lure us into the
apps yeah because that's how they make
money
yeah cuz when we get in then we see the
ads and they make money yeah it's just
an insane process in like you you were
describing earlier the attention the the
nervous systems we're being you know how
do we take these things back with
software like CFO yeah I don't think
there's a silver bullet we certainly
don't claim to be yeah so it's great
that there's a whole ecosystem of
developers that are poking at this from
different angles I think that we we were
the first to really take this complete
solution that meets people where they're
at no one else has done an interface on
Android until we did and now there's a
couple new ones out there and yeah it
really gives us the opportunity to
reimagine every part of the user
experience from the lock screen to the
notification deliver a to what happens
if you're in an app that you have
decided is one you want to use less we
can do really cool things to augment
what the screen looks like and yeah
basically help you yes you yeah so
whilst let's show some of this show a
couple more slides yeah shall we show
sure yeah yeah okay so okay so this is
what the home screen looks like and the
home screen again is just like you set
an intention you maybe add an emoji
you're constantly you know brought back
to this screen yeah and the you know
there's not just the flurry of apps
right in the home screen
yeah it's ludicrous that you would see a
vending machine of corporate logos
vending machine of Corp every time you
open your phone 150 times a day yeah
that's like why would you do that but
that's the default and so we believe
that there are more skillful things that
you could see so our home screen doesn't
allow those icons and we we prompt you
to enter an intention something that
would be skillful free to be reminded of
and there's a bunch of other things that
we plan on doing with this home screen
but like in terms of cognitive real
estate like yeah this is really freaking
important you're spending
many people are spending hours a day on
this thing yeah and so there's a real
opportunity at least what I'm inspired
by is that 85% of the world has Android
phones right so it's like billions of
people and if we can influence what that
homescreen and what that interface
experience looks and feels like we can
we can really help people live better
and I don't claim to know exactly how to
do that yeah but I think we're doing a
lot no thanks that's beautiful I think
we're trying we're trying like we we
make a strong effort to have different
voices in the room more than half our
cap table is women people of color LGBTQ
oh I spend a lot of my free time trying
to understand different ways of knowing
so we're not just trying to solve this
problem the same consciousness but we're
really trying to integrate you know
science contemplative even business yeah
psyche energy healing some of the
features are inspired by that yeah so
yeah there's just all this wisdom
available old early and I really feel my
job is to be this great discernment
filter and and that's really fun so
imagine if the larger technology
companies took into account that
multidisciplinary approach to with
spirit adding spirituality to Twitter
yeah book just change things so much so
you just you you brought up this very
fascinating point right when you
launched into the cognitive real-estate
yeah we use these things 150 times a day
that's an average
it's insane and then the currently with
a lot of what I'm writing about I'm
writing about neuro real estate just the
limitation in real estate that we have
so you get to pick what you want to fill
it with every single day and depending
on that that's what's gonna compound
over time that's who you're gonna become
yep so you you're like a vending machine
of corporate icons I thought that was
very interesting way to put it if you're
if you're unlock screen for your home
screen the first page is a flurry of
icons that is gonna be who you
who you become if your homescreen is a
beautiful photo with an intention of
maybe pause for a deep breath you may
decrease the amount of times you access
a phone from 150 a day to maybe a
hundred a day and you may also take a
second thought at oh now that my
Facebook or Instagram apps are not right
there on the home page maybe I didn't
need to go there maybe I should go
outside and take some breaths and enjoy
some fresh air and talk to someone
because I see these beautiful trees yeah
or a bird or water or something else on
the home screen yeah yeah we can
intervene in so many different places
as we'll see in the next yeah demos
alright yeah let's pull let's pull up
the next yeah that's what's so cool
about this everyone now has these super
computers in their pocket and they could
be used for our objectives but they're
mostly engineered for corporate
objectives so we're really just there's
like so much so much attention is
flowing like right now it's mostly if
the average person spends five hours a
day on these things which is nuts it's
like a third of their waking lives
yeah and it's exactly right it's a
there's a problem with statistics in
this space there's a whole range but
yeah I've heard that number several
times yeah especially because where most
people work on a computer all day now
and so because of that as well and most
people the tech sector at least and so
because of that that's at least eight
hours yeah more than half of your waking
life right yeah yeah so consumers are
waking up and realizing oh wait I don't
know if I want those five hours to be on
the same like three companies like you
know Facebook YouTube whatever so
there's a whole bunch of people looking
for tools and looking for places to put
that attention instead and one of the
things that we're hopeful about is that
in the time and space we free up for
people we can help them develop
healthier habits around self compassion
mindfulness human connection and we can
connect them to really amazing services
proprietary or partners that are able to
basically help people with what they're
looking for you know yeah it's it's
really cool and then things can move
really fast yeah this is a this is also
an extremely important feature I was
driving this you know we have will show
everyone a demo as well in just a little
bit as we go through these features but
this sort of notion that you can be
pushed in notification whenever the app
wants it's this isn't even this is no
longer when Ron messages me I get the
notification but this is when I open up
my phone after maybe a period of thirty
minutes and I you know I see that there
was that message there I might swipe it
away then Facebook or Gmail might see
the fact that you're on your phone and
then they will send you a push
notification saying that oh you got this
message I'll be like I just swipe that
away and I just I know you're trying to
lure me into using the service yeah so
here you can actually back your
notifications every 30 minutes every
hour once a day like the mail like the
mail otherwise doing a corporation
schedule your thoughts and most people
don't think about that sense of agency
that they're relinquishes in this social
contract that has grown grown grown but
yeah this is a no-brainer we also let
you VIP certain apps that could still
get through like if you want your boss
to be able to contact you yes
yeah the VIPs yeah it's just like we
want the phone to be smart to your life
and there kenri if it's designed so but
you know the design has to fit with the
objectives at the top yes you know yes
the principles the the principles the
value system what you said it what you
design it to want to do rather than what
the corporate interests design it to
want for you to behave it with for
monetary purposes yeah yeah okay so
we'll explore that and in the demo
Ronnie let's move to the next one so
this is the this is when you swipe one
screen over from the home screen this is
what you get which as you can see there
are no corporate logos on this yeah
and so Maps goes to Google Maps
Transport goes to either like uber lyft
whatever you want to set it you calendar
with Google a Google Calendar
payment can go to venmo or whatever you
want so when you click messages it's
interesting because then you can
actually see all the different messaging
apps so you know just then it's an extra
click yep but then you don't you know
then you don't see and so okay so yeah
do you want to unpack this a little bit
more yeah you did a great job of
summarizing it
we've unbranded in grayscale all of the
icons rescale too so you're less likely
to get sidetracked on the way in or the
way out of what you're doing yes and
less likely to pick up the cognitive
load of seeing that you have a new
tinder match or a new email and this is
one tier of our three-tiered menus so we
keep the tools the utilitarian stuff
closest and then all the way on the
third page is apps that you've flagged
for a best use so when you first on
board and we'll show you in the demo
yeah we'll recommend you know social
media news media dating gaming video
because people cite that those are
things that make them less happy but
overuse yeah and so we have a whole bag
of tricks there that we use basically
the same tricks that marketers and
behavior designers used to get you to
you know do something and do it more and
longer we use those same tricks but for
the user for the well being for the well
being sightings for the what for what
the user wants yeah you use those strip
yeah which yeah yeah yeah actually yeah
I was gonna say when do marketers
grayscale and unbranded or you know yeah
okay so and then when you let's go to
the next one Ron this one's better
explained in the demo but this is what
I'm most proud of I think this thing
this encompasses a lot of the ethos of
Sampo did I tell you what Sampo means I
feel it was always in Spanish yeah yeah
it's a plan siempre always siempre campo
time oh that's right
siempre always tiempo time yeah oh
that's the original meaning two years
ago when we were thinking like always
being mindful of the time you spend on
things that's good
then I was it's good I was in the desert
a few weeks ago and I don't know at some
point I was just like okay Sampo what do
you mean to me like you know is there is
there's a deeper meaning and it was so
cool it came within seconds it was like
oh the tiempo is time technology the
material logical mechanical masculine
siempre is always the infinite yeah love
feminine intuitive
Sampo is about balancing those two
energies those two worlds and I'm the
embodiment of that yeah and I was like
done great moving on next next meeting
challenge beauty challenge see I'll show
you this in person okay I will and then
we have Ronda we have another one that
we want to show before yet should we
show this one before yeah yes this is
just kind of to explain I mean we
struggle with explaining like what is
the Sampo is a layer and operating
system is skin a lot of people in the
Bay Area at least don't really
understand how the Android ecosystem
works but because Android is an
operating system that is given out to
all these hardware manufacturers with
nuanced specs Android allows the harbor
manufacturers to make their own
interface for the Samsung interface is
slightly different the LG from the pixel
and that also means that third-party
developers can tinker - yes and so there
have been some productivity oriented
ones and like a Hello Kitty type phone
Facebook actually had the opportunity to
make a Facebook phone but they they put
the news feed on the lockscreen which
was too invasive for they put the news
feed on the lockscreen I remember you
yes yeah cool okay I remember using that
yeah Wow
thank you for reminding me about that
five years ago I was a brilliant idea
they just you know it was too much I it
was full screen full screen it was like
a home screen full home screen was your
Facebook it was just it was yes then
each post was like a whole yeah it was
crazy I'm glad you brought that up
because they didn't have an opportunity
like you said imagine if like YouTube or
Twitter try taking over your home
landing page yeah
yeah I mean I yeah this is like a PSA I
hope some companies try this like I
think the meditation apps have a really
great opportunity and when we open
source our code like they'll just be
able to do that like if like call more
headspace would be a home page right and
yeah they would be able to elevate their
content for the user so it would create
a much more loyal like engaging
experience and deprioritize all the
candy the junk food yes yes so like
basically CM PO plus one of those things
would be really powerful there's a lot
of potential there yeah this is a really
important point that I just want to make
sure people got is that Android over
time has enabled you to to tinker with
the OS the Android operating system in
terms of just being able to put like a
skin on top of the OS like what Samsung
or LG does for their for how they put
something on top of the Android OS for
example with CM PO cm Poe is able to
come in on top of Android and put the
skin on top on the home page versus with
Apple Apple doesn't give you that
ability Apple you can't just load up
another where you click the home button
and you're not on the normal iOS we
can't do any of this stuff on iOS and it
sucks I mean sucks for consumers
products for this passionate developer
ecosystem that's really innovative and
mission driven Apple doesn't let us
exist or it really limits the amount
that we can help people yeah Apple is
even starting to kick some of us out of
the App Store because they seemingly
want to control the narrative here
because I mean basically like any
existence and the success of an app like
ours on the app store is validating the
harms that the device is is having on
people and yeah it's a bummer but like
like these companies have the cash to
launch a space race in Manhattan Project
to figure out how to create a better
relationship with tech yeah but they're
not because they there's no incentive
it's not great for business at least not
yet it might be over time you know 5-10
years
totally maybe faster I hope so ah maybe
that's a good X PRIZE model we should
talk to Naveen Jane and demand us and
yeah we should talk to them and push
them for ethical tech X PRIZE oh yeah
like a million dollar one to see if we
can get put more pressure on to write
Facebook and Google and Apple and say
that you know make more moves in this
direction yes yeah which you are doing
yourself because this is now becoming
open-source as well yeah yeah so
basically we decided over the summer so
Apple and Google launched a few features
to help people manage the screen time
and it's very small buts a step in the
right direction you a lot of people feel
it's just to appease the PR pressure and
you shareholder pressure yeah but it
spooked a lot of the investors we were
talking to and you know already we're
really discerning about the types of
people who wanna accept money from and
that's a very small pool of people who
are thinking a little bit differently
about capital and about you know impact
but yeah unfortunately a lot of the
investors that we were building rapport
with they you know they're intimidated
by Apple and Google get into the space
yeah
and rightfully so so I kind of felt like
I could brute force the next hundred
meetings that's the conventional wisdom
just like you know get through it and
and get some money but I was like you
know what I've been working really hard
on this a year and a half I I could use
a little slowing down living the mission
you know taking time for myself
yeah going on a meditation retreat
getting some nature stuff like that
so that's what I did this summer and it
let's do some explorations into some
some tangentially related areas the
conscious investing and social justice
lens and this digital wellness warriors
community which I can talk about later
and then what kind of came through it
was like maybe maybe we're not serving
this collective mission the best by
being a for-profit silo company that
raises the hour by dollar and gets the
user by user one by one like what's a
what's a bigger theory of change here
that that is in line with the ethos
narrower values of Sampo and so
I don't know anything about insource but
I've been learning and it seems like
there's real opportunity to basically
put this code out there and invite a
growing community of motivated
developers and designers researchers who
really want to work on projects like
this they want to work in service of
this mission but there's no jobs because
there's so little funding for this type
of stuff yeah but we've built a really
high integrity brand and team and
product over the last three years of you
know writing about this and talking
about it so I want to collaborate with
those people and really yeah basically
launch this space race figure out like
all the different possibilities
prototype those and show the bigger
companies Apple Samsung LG Google etc
what's possible and so they can just
imitate them and then voila success now
the stuff that we created with the
ecosystem is on everyone's phone by
default and five billion people have
healthy relationships with technology
and can live and work and love from that
place instead of a more like fear
heightened nervous system like hijacking
attention space and so that's why I'm
exploring trying to figure out how to
pull it off but it feels right and I'm
super it goes yeah you need another
high-five yeah yeah but not too hard you
know also like trusting in the flow of
things and you know going
I feel supported and I yeah there's
there's no rush and there's urgency its
paradox yeah yeah it's the best paradox
exactly okay so you brought up a couple
of really important points there one
that I think is right before we go to
demo is the open sourcing of everything
as you open source everything you get
you fruit you first of all you're going
against a paradigm of the investor
dollar by dollar user by user mentality
we had Christine Peterson on the show
from 4sight Institute who was who was
given the sort of accreditation for
coining open source and so you know when
we were talking to her about it we were
definitely very excited about just this
huge influx of like good
positivity and just you know kind of
like this heart energy that comes into
into things when you open source it
versus the idea of like closed off IP
mentality and there's this whole thing
between the US and China and I'm he and
the fact and like what's going on and so
when you when you come down to open
sourcing and being able to get this
community of engineers and designers and
ethical tech peeps that get involved in
it like you said you're gonna have a
space race for tech for yeah flourishing
yeah and then that's gonna really push
five billion people into the is the door
and that's amazing and I love that
mission a hundred percent behind you and
behind Tristana and the time walk meant
and and the other people at the
forefront of this we we desperately
desperately need need this yeah well
we're actually you know we're hosting a
an event on November on November
fifteenth on ethical tech oh and you
should definitely be one of our I'll be
there one of our you should be one of
our panelists yeah yeah okay let's do it
yeah
okay cool it's no time to thinks well
yeah yeah we gotta figure it out in this
lifetime yeah and yeah we're hosting an
event augments on the attention economy
on the nervous side of things on all
these different things thank you for the
warning Ronnie on a timer
all right let's let's whip out the
that's what about the tech go all right
so go and deploy yeah go ahead plop down
here take a seat with us cuz you're
gonna walk us through this yep
and we're gonna get a zoom got us good
Ron all right cool alright so here's the
home screen so we set our intention to
love the couple cute emojis and so you
know when you when you open up you know
that's how you move over to the screen
that we were showing you guys earlier
yeah honestly we did pretty good demo
before you know here's where you can
customize the intention and here's where
you can pass your notifications so you
can decide they come all the time every
15 30 top the hour
this is this is RIT this part super
important you know you can all you can
select only at one time so like like
every three or like wait yeah later
later on in the day I only want to see
it one time or just times three times
yeah that's that's really good yeah my
CTL that's that one yeah that was so
good and then yeah we have these menus
first screen other for clean use apps
and then this is cool this is that third
page so these are apps that on
onboarding we recommend and you can add
or remove ones so that to the and if
they're on this page one you'll notice
the contrast is lower because yeah light
dark contrast is more important to the
brain to into attentional processing in
the brain see where snapchat is now
every time you come back to this page
oh no that's a coincidence snapchat will
be in a different location so there's a
random number generator that sorts the
apps in a new way so that way they're
not in the same place right let's see if
something doesn't have been to it to it
your thumb doesn't habituates you and oh
my gosh imagine you know every time you
go to the home screen that on your home
screen where you have that what did what
did you call it a vending machine of
corporate logos your your thumb has
habituated to going to the area so even
if you're done using your phone you'll
still habituate to going to Instagram or
whatever because is you know yeah yeah
it's it's accessible so that's the whole
thing with behavior design we you know
we work with BJ Foggs behavior grid
behavior model we love them oh yeah yeah
it's also with their near this Stanford
habit lab and as well which made that
app on Chrome which yeah it does though
yeah it's all about manipulating the
ability triggers and motivation so you
come to this page and we've lowered your
ability to easily get to the app you
wanted to we're motivating you with your
intention at the top the intention stays
there yeah remind me of it yeah
and there's some cool stuff we can do
showing you in other places throughout
the UI yeah and then triggers see this
bar that's on here yeah so no one's ever
done anything like this before but this
is a screen cover where we're showing
you in real time how much time we're
spending on it and we're also offering
you alternative options like opening
your notes up or opening your meditation
and interesting and this will grow with
every minute and start to take up more
of your screen and you can still use it
and you can move this thing around so
you can you know type in whatever but
eventually it just gets to fill up half
the screen oh it also sends messages
along the way like inside of the screen
cover it'll prompt you to reflect on how
you're feeling
remind of your intention the other it
will send met little messages as well
they'll just appear they want they'll
appear
come in like a notification but the
point is like we are instead of instead
of what other apps do which is put a
notification like get off this now
you've exceeded your limit like a very
like forceful and you know kind of
masculine approach we're taking a more
gentle gradual here see it's at 57 so
it's gonna resize you to do hey there
you go oh look at that that's a big
increase with it you can move it down
you can rotate it oh you can oh wow
that's quite yeah yeah man that Android
really lets you put that skin on top and
and that's huge there's so much we can
do with this and as a behavior design
tool our hypothesis is this is a lot
more effective at getting to do the
thing you want to do then the
notification and I mean yeah I just want
to rehash the point so everything is a
notification now right if you're at
least different from a notification yes
that's a huge part of exactly I like how
you have you know notes and wellness up
as well yeah so what we should maybe we
should also so let's go let's go to
let's say we do want to pull up okay so
you can pull up your notes yeah you can
go back so okay so is there something
else that we should show here
that's pretty there's a couple other
small things but yeah those are those
are the main things for now this is our
beta and yeah I just want to rehash that
and get tiempo.com
you know links in the bio go down
didn't check it out yeah Android only um
yep androids the platform for people who
care about this whether a CEO in sumer
or a developer yep they were really
grateful that we have the opportunity to
use our imagination and creativity you
actually innovate you know Apple
unfortunately we've you know we've tried
to figure out a way to have a better
better access developer permissions but
but out of all all of the smartphone
market 85% of it is Android across the
world yeah yeah so then there's that
that's a majority of users yeah imagine
the next billion people on the internet
leap frogging the attention economy leap
frogging the attention economy I love
the empower with tools to be a super
event yeah yeah where are other things
we want to show on on add those the man
those are the main oh that's cool yeah
yeah everyone check out CMO get CMO comm
if you have an Android phone for Android
tablet you know go and check it out get
it downloaded even if you don't go and
sit down with your friend that has one
and going download CFO down the Play
Store and go and test it you know go and
play with this realize what is going on
and how you can make things better by
trying things like this and better
understanding the control mechanisms
that are going on underneath of how we
use these devices and how we can take
control of our lives through these
device through the software like this
that goes yeah and if you want to work
on this project get in contact with me
Andrew at CM poco si EMP o.co yep
Android TM poco soon to be Ava at CM
poco like that yeah I've never heard
that yeah that feels better
that's so amazing to see that in action
and you know into you to feel you
working on this and I love your visions
I love the way that you're like imagine
the next billion people leap frogging
the attention economy the next billion
people that get on smartphones should
not have to deal with the attention
economy no I love that vision that's
what makes me get up in the morning
you know that these are the types of
quotes that get me up in the morning
because uh it's really easy to get up in
the morning and to look at your device
and be like we are so screwed if you're
stuck in the attention economy forever
yeah yeah and then there's the other way
of waking up in the morning and being
like the next billion people are not
gonna have to deal with this yeah I love
that yeah that makes me want to get up
in the morning it's me you know happier
makes me want to get more conscious
angels than 9cm posso okay
let's talk about this on the way out is
there another ron was there another
image at the at the end it's a banner of
kind of what we went through and then
it's there one more which is the videos
last right okay yeah so let's let's
unpack on the digital wellness warriors
and conscious angels on the way because
these are also in the warned wisdom
these are also things that you're you
know you're building simultaneously so
excuse me so right now we have a lot of
people that work in the technology
sector that are not that are not focused
on digital wellness that is not their
priority to understand you were just
talking about taking a break and going
on meditation or going in nature or
taking time for you mm-hmm
how do we get more people to realize
that taking time for you it's so crucial
yeah I really feel that's the chilling
to our question you know some people say
like how do we wake up the world how do
we you know meet people where they're at
how can we use these tools not just to
de-stress but really be a door to inner
work and I I love that question like I
would love to continue talking about it
it's I think it's really curious that
you have a lot of tech leaders investors
people in Hollywood starting to starting
to look for these experiences to improve
themselves and
you know recondition themselves yeah and
and start to spread that wisdom and
really show what's possible like when
someone becomes more kind and
compassionate and centered it it rubs
off yeah it's totally does I think that
like that like really seeing people
transform is a better way than like you
know having HR say hey we now have a
head space subscription everyone do it
now and then like you know maybe 1% of
people try it and get into it and then
okay they they're distressing but you
know what
but it's hard like personal growth is a
lifelong thing yeah but I feel like
there's more there's more and more
on-ramps people are finding them through
things like Burning Man through
meditation people are pissed about the
administration people are inheriting
money from boomers at like
ever-increasing rates there's just all
these trends that are kind of
intersecting and I feel that I wake up
every day grateful to be alive in this
time yeah having the the privilege to
work on projects and service of this
team humanities spaceship earth
collective thing they're all trying to
like and while I like working on
different departments trying to figure
out how to make it work and yeah it's
exciting you give me lots of hope Thanks
I got plenty I mean when it comes down
to it I've had untold privileges and so
I feel like it's I feel a strong sense
responsibility to figure out how to
leverage those for social good so a lot
of the things that I'm creating are
really expressions of that it's like oh
I went to this extremely resource
institution with influential alumni and
I've been embarrassed about that I've
like wanted to hide that in the past and
now I'm like wow how can I use that
power and so I created the alumni
community of people who are interested
in personal growth and integrating that
with their work in the world partially
to connect us because I want to meet
those people because there's this weird
thing about alumni where we feel like oh
like we'll accept that LinkedIn
connection and talk to you but also I
want to like make it cooler for other
people who are stuck in you know sleepy
jobs that you know a bank or consulting
firm or big tech company or whatever and
are hungry for more like deep down know
that something's off
and need permission and safe spaces to
start exploring and consuming and then
be plugged in to you know yes these
departments that need help and money and
other skills yeah these are the people
that are right there at the pull-up bar
and they're almost you know under full
pull up and you're just giving them that
little boost up with digital wellness
yeah conscious angel open arms open arms
yeah yeah yeah and it's telling stories
new stories because the story is if you
go through a place like Wharton are
really strong like it can seem like
there's nothing else that really matters
and when do we see in new speeds when do
we see though you know the digital
wellness helping us make a pull up it's
almost always fear fear greed oh yeah
war yeah so it's good to have a little
bit of digital wellness in our new
speeds is also extremely important yeah
I love I love your mentality additional
wellness warriors there's so many
different ways to tackle that there's so
many different variables that are going
on there it's a whole other thing to
unpack with you unconscious investing
conscious yeah very careful about who
you take money from you're also careful
about you know how to we do this too we
talk to people a lot about you know
where they're putting money and whatnot
and and going into conscious investments
is more important than anything else
right now that's how you guide
civilization towards our yes our
collective goals
yeah and less away from the self and the
greed and this just yeah it's I think
maybe the next evolution of social
Darwinism is when we care more about the
selflessness we care more about the
empathy we care more about the
collective rather than the self that
will be a very interesting sort of
transition to discuss in evolution yeah
we're with adult developmental theory
and some of these frameworks for yeah
like human evolution what was the name
again adult development adult
developmental theory yeah and who was it
again this I I don't know too much about
it yeah but yeah it's basically
what you describing like capacity for
empathy for holding divergent viewpoints
and yeah really being able to like
ability to remove yourself from the
thoughts and feelings and stories to
think critically about them and yeah
like not just like react and so you know
we like the people creating our
institutions and making decisions
creating or technology are maybe maybe
somewhere on there and now we're
figuring out how we can like elevate
that level yes and so once we have more
people creating stuff from that place
yes I think we we have a lot more to be
hopeful about because technology can be
an incredible agent of human flourishing
of civilization democracy what have you
yes but it really matters like who's
making it yeah who's funding it you know
how you're really like how you're
relating core values and principles of
the building process yeah yeah how
you're relating yeah okay let's ask you
a couple of these quick questions on the
way out um do you think we're alone in
the cosmos so I used to actually be
really into aliens UFOs and stuff like
that it was the first book series I was
obsessed with was called area 51 that my
dads are being together I - and then
lately I feel like I've heard more and
more scientists that sharing with me
their ideas about how maybe we're the
first and I kind of like that and you
know there's a few reasons why I like it
was mostly hydrogen universe for the
first few billion years we've we've
directed study a bunch of places and
heard nothing the probability of like
this species being able to escape the
biosphere is like one in how many
millions of species have done planet
Earth so yeah it's very possible were
the only ones and that gives me just a
lot of excitement for this moment in
time for for this lifetime but I have
the privilege to be in and and got to be
where I am and working on the thing I am
it's like I feel like I I get called to
really play a leadership role in this
bigger movement to like initiate into
humanity's adulthood in a scenario
well than everything and it's like and I
think it's possible but like you were
kind of looking to before the
predominant story is about um you know
ethical attack it's like it's all about
reducing harm I don't think we're
telling enough stories about the
positive impacts of the positive effects
of technology that are possible yeah and
and I'm guilty of that too and I feel
like this is an interesting way in which
cientos evolution and mine have been in
parallel where most of what we do right
now is about preventing the persuasive
techniques of addicting apps and
limiting and reducing safety there's
some stuff that's aspirational like the
intention type stuff and wellness but
yeah I'm really pumped to start leaning
into more of that and telling more of a
positive story that people can actually
rally around we needed something to
rally around so yeah I'm gonna be that
thing yeah okay and then how about do
you think we are in a simulation no I
think this is base reality what's that
yeah yeah it's not about too much yeah
like my my instinct is that no but like
how you define a simulation like yeah
Anna yeah because if everything happened
from the Big Bang until now is a
simulation then we don't even know but
yeah but okay so you think this is real
this is base reality of this yeah it's
real but I think there's energies and
forces beyond comprehension
totally and and like if you call that
design a simulation maker then IO I
might agree that we're in a simulation
but yeah you know maybe in like the pop
culture like you know someone in the
year 3000 he was like playing a game and
like I'm the avatar like I I don't feel
that deal feel like okay well then
there's like retrocausality time lives
our coding the past in the future at the
same time and so maybe if I just don't
know enough about that stuff it's
fascinating what exists outside the 3d
and
time all this stuff so fascinated yeah
simulation theory that's why we like to
ask about it here people's opinions yeah
last question Ava the last question what
do you think the most beautiful thing in
the world and I love sunsets it's so
cool to be in relationship with a star
and experience the subtle textures of
the environment changing and you have
that intimate moment with nature and
self yeah I haven't seen one in a little
while yeah I love how you described it
yeah that was really beautiful
Wow what a great show on technology for
human flourishing Oh feels so good you
know I feel so so much cool I feel so
hopeful you know I feel really good you
know I feel clean mm-hmm I feel clean
from from the the the vending machine of
corporate logos you know I feel I feel
really good a way from that I want to
say thank you thank you so much
everything after coming out of the show
up today thank you for talking to us and
for teaching us Ron thank you our
producer director thank you everyone for
coming and for enjoying the show let us
know what you think in the comments
below we'd love to hear from you what
you feel we'd love to know and chat with
you in the community also check out that
link in the bio for get cm go give it a
download give it a go talk about it with
friends let's regain reclaim our minds
and our souls from the sort of vending
machine of corporate logos and the
attention economy infrastructure so
let's get talking about that and get
building as you guys know go build to go
build with what you learned today go
make blogs go make videos go make
pictures go make images make businesses
go start things and create make art go
make into the world thank you everyone
for tuning in much love and we will see
you soon love
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]